so when i was in art school i developed
a shake in my hand and this was the
straightest line i could draw
now in hindsight it was actually good
for some things like mixing a can of
paint or shaking a polaroid
but at the time this was really doomsday
this is this is the destruction of my
dream of becoming an artist
the shake developed out of
really a single-minded pursuit of
pointillism just years of making tiny
tiny dots and eventually these dots went
from
being perfectly round to looking more
like tadpoles because of the shake
so to compensate i'd hold the pen
tighter and this progressively made the
shake worse so i'd hold the pen tighter
still
and this became a vicious cycle that
ended up causing so much pain and joint
issues i had trouble holding anything
and after
spending all my life wanting to do art i
left art school
and then i left art completely
but after a few years i just couldn't
stay away from art and i decided to go
to a neurologist about the shake and
discovered i had permanent nerve damage
and
he actually took one look at my squiggly
line and said well why don't you just
embrace the shake
so i did i went home i grabbed a pencil
and i just started letting my hand shake
and shake i was making all these
scribble pictures
and even though it wasn't the kind of
art that i was ultimately passionate
about it felt great
and more importantly once i embraced the
shake i realized i could still make art
i just had to find a different approach
to making the art that i wanted
now i still enjoyed the fragmentation of
pointillism seeing these little tiny
dots come together to make this unified
hole so i began experimenting with other
ways to fragment images where the shake
wouldn't affect the work like dipping my
feet in paint and walking on a canvas
or in a 3d structure consisting of two
by fours
creating a 2d image
by burning it with a blowtorch
i discovered that if i worked in a
larger scale with bigger materials my
hand really wouldn't hurt
and after having gone from a single
approach to art
i ended up having an approach to
creativity that completely changed my
artistic horizons
this was the first time i'd encountered
this idea that embracing the limitation
could actually drive creativity
at the time i was finishing up school
and i was so excited to get a real job
and finally afford new art supplies i
had this horrible little set of tools
and
i felt like i could do so much more with
the supplies i thought an artist was
supposed to have
i actually didn't even have a regular
pair of scissors i was using these metal
sheers until i stole a pair from the
office that i worked at
so i got out of school i got a job i got
a paycheck i got myself to the art store
and i just went nuts buying supplies
and then when i got home i sat down and
i set myself to test to
really try to create something just
completely outside of the box
but i sat there for hours
and nothing came to mind
the same thing the next day and then the
next
quickly slipping into a creative slump
and i was in a dark place for a long
time unable to create
and it didn't make any sense because i
was finally able to support my art and
yet i was creatively blank
but as i searched around in the darkness
i realized i was actually paralyzed by
all the choices that i never had before
and it was then that i thought back to
my jittery hands
embraced the shake
and i realized if i ever wanted my
creativity back i had to quit trying so
hard to think outside of the box
and get back into it
i wondered could you become more
creative than by looking for limitations
what if i could only create with a
dollars worth of supplies
at this point i was spending a lot of my
evenings and well i guess i still spent
a lot of my evenings in starbucks but i
know you can ask for an extra cup if you
want one so i decided to ask for 50.
surprisingly they just handed them right
over and then with some pencils i
already had i made this project for only
80 cents
it really became a moment of
clarification for me that
we need to first be limited
in order to become
limitless i took this approach of
thinking inside the box to my canvas and
wondered what if instead of painting on
a canvas i could only paint on my chest
so i painted 30 images one layer at a
time one on top of another with each
picture representing an influence in my
life
or what if instead of painting with a
brush i could only paint with karate
chops
so i dip my hands in paint and i just i
just attacked the canvas and i actually
hit so hard that i bruised a joint in my
pinky and it was stuck straight for a
couple weeks
or
what if what if instead of relying on
myself
i had to rely on other people to create
the content for the art so for six days
i lived in front of a webcam i slept on
the floor and i ate takeout and i asked
people to call me and share a story with
me about a life-changing moment
their stories became the art as i wrote
them onto the revolving canvas
or
what if instead of making art to display
i had to destroy it
this seemed like the ultimate limitation
being an artist without art
this destruction idea turned into a
year-long project that i called goodbye
art where each and every piece of art
had to be destroyed after its creation
in the beginning of goodbye art i focus
on force destruction like this image of
jimi hendrix made with over 7000 matches
then i opened it up to creating art that
was destroyed naturally i looked for
temporary materials
like spitting out food
sidewalk chalk
[Applause]
and even frozen wine
the the last iteration of destruction
was to try to produce something that
didn't actually exist in the first place
so i organized candles on a table i lit
them and then blew them out then
repeated this process over and over with
the same set of candles
then assembled the videos into the
larger image
so the end image was never visible as a
physical hole
it was destroyed before it ever existed
in the course of this goodbye r series i
created 23 different pieces with nothing
left to physically display
what i thought would be the ultimate
limitation actually turned out to be the
ultimate liberation as each time i
created the destruction brought me back
to a neutral place where
i felt refreshed and ready to start the
next project
it didn't it did not happen overnight
there were times in my projects failed
to get off the ground or even worse
after spending tons of time on them the
end image was kind of embarrassing but
having committed to the process i
continued on and something really
surprising came out of this as i
destroyed each project
i was learning to let go
let go of outcomes
let go of failures and let go of
imperfections
and in return i found a process of
creating art that's perpetual and
unencumbered by results
i found myself in a state of constant
creation thinking only of what's next
and coming up with more ideas than ever
when i think back to my three years away
from art
away from my dream just going through
the motions
instead of trying to find a different
way to continue that dream
i just quit i gave up
and what if i didn't embrace the shake
because embracing the shake for me
wasn't just about arts and having art
skills
it turned out to be about life and
having life skills
because ultimately most of what we do
takes place here
inside the box with limited resources
learning to be creative within the
confines of our limitations
is the best hope we have to transform
ourselves
and collectively transform our world
looking at limitations as a source of
creativity
changed the course of my life
now when i run into a barrier or i find
myself creatively stumped
i sometimes still struggle but i
continue to show up for the process and
try to remind myself of the
possibilities
like using hundreds of real live worms
to make an image
using a push pin to tattoo a banana
or painting a picture with hamburger
grease
one of my most recent endeavors is to
try to translate the habits of
creativity that i've learned into
something others can replicate
limitations
may be the most unlikely of places to
harness creativity
but perhaps
one of the best ways to get ourselves
out of ruts
rethink categories and challenge
accepted norms
and instead of telling each other to
seize the day
maybe
we can remind ourselves every day
to seize the limitation
thank you
[Music]
you